today on the matt wall show the election
is not determined yet but the result
whatever it is ultimately is already far
from what the media and the polls
predicted how did they get it so wrong
again and do we have to be worried about
voter fraud
what else can we determine based on what
we know so far all these questions and
many more we'll talk about today but
first
a word from our friends at rockauto i
tell you about
rockauto.com all the time and there's
good reason for that they're just a
great company a great service
it's really as simple as that i use them
all the time myself because rockauto.com
is so much easier than walking into a
store and someone demanding quick
answers to things like
is your odyssey an lx or an ex and then
they usually just have to order it
online anyway because there are so many
types of cards impossible to keep them
all stocked
you have access to rockauto.com at your
desk
in your pocket rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear
like airlines do in other industries why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts really as
simple as that like say you happen to
need a a delphi
fg 1456 fuel pump assembly
you know like i need that kind of thing
all the time for a 2005 2010 honda
odyssey
and it costs like 354 dollars at a big
change store
that's the kind of thing you can get at
rockauto.com for 217 bucks
the rockauto.com catalog is unique easy
to navigate quickly see all the parts
available
for your vehicle and choose the brand
specifications and prices you prefer
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available
for your car truck and remember always
to write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box
so that they know that we sent you and
then i get all the credit which is
really important as well all right
we're going to get away from the normal
show format a little bit just for today
most likely though we'll see what
happens with the rest of the week
um what what i want to do is
go through what we know so far and um
how i'm at least processing some of this
and thinking about it
i can't tell you how you should process
it or think about it all i can do is
tell you
my own thoughts and i'm i'm desperately
hoping
that as i speak these words they will
not be made
irrelevant by events developing in real
time of course it's better for the
country if we
get legitimate clarity and closure but
it would be bad for
the reach of this episode of my podcast
and really
what's more important the country or my
podcast it's a toss-up at least i think
we can all agree on that
so um in any case let's talk about what
we know
we know that there was no democrat
blue wave landslide there was no
overwhelming
repudiation of the evil orange man the
american people did not run
smiling and weeping with open arms
towards marxism
uh there was also no uh republican land
side
though no credible person was
forecasting or expecting that
no credible person was forecasting a
democrat landslide either
though lots of lots of people were
forecasting and just no credible people
were
it's the problem is that most of the
people who do the forecasting in
politics
just like most of the people who do the
forecasting of our weather
are not credible and not reliable and
are more or wrong more often than
they're not
in this case as you've probably heard
um the the polls were absurdly wrong
especially in states like florida and
also elsewhere in the country
as i said on the election special last
night if you watch that on dailywire.com
at this point we have to view pollsters
the same way we view
like hotline psychics
a person who identifies themselves as a
pollster ought to be
greeted with all of the same respect and
deference
as miss cleo i'll put it this way if
pollsters still have a job after this
election then i want to be one
i am leaving the daily wire to work to
be a pollster
or maybe i could be the daily wires
official pollster it
you know it would mean that i can say
whatever i want i can be wrong nearly
100
of the time and still get paid which on
second thought already pretty much
describes what i do
so i guess i don't need to change but
either way the polls are a laughing
stock and you will be a laughingstock
yourself from henceforth should you
quote them
why are the polls wrong well maybe the
methodology behind drawing
sweeping conclusions about hundreds of
millions of people based on
phone conversations with 900 registered
voters is fundamentally flawed
and maybe there are only certain kinds
of people who will even talk to a
pollster in the first place
and that selection bias makes the
conclusion useless
maybe it has something to do with all
that i don't know what else do we know
we know that uh president trump win or
lose
actually made gains with minority voters
especially hispanics
we know that the democrats massively
underperformed in important senate races
republicans seem poised to keep the
senate
again even if biden wins these are major
defeats for the democrats
why did it happen this way well there
are a number of easy answers
they ran a guy who has dementia for one
thing that's a problem
that has to factor in the democrat party
also over the last several years
rather than expanding their coalition to
bring more people under the tent
has done the opposite and narrowed their
message and appeal
at this point seemingly trying to target
a coalition
of media pundits college professors
19 year old white girls who have nose
rings and dye their hair on natural
colors
and blm activists of course there's a
lot of crossover in those groups i mean
those
some people are all of those things but
um that's been their focus
critical race theory gender theory
screaming incessantly about america's
evil past systemic racism transgender
eight-year-olds
these are the kinds of issues and
arguments and ideas and concepts that
the democrat party has presented
it doesn't have a wide appeal it turns
out the appeal is certainly wider than
i'd like for it to be because i think it
should have an appeal that extends to
zero people but it's not as wide as the
democrats thought
and hoped when it comes to the minority
vote specifically we know that the left
ever since the formation of black lives
matter has decided
that black lives matter the organization
is the same as
black people the two are interchangeable
in the minds of the left
which is why if you criticize black
lives matter as i'm sure you've noticed
you're also criticizing black people
according to them
it's racist to attack blm they told us
because they draw no distinction between
blm the organization
and the demographic group it supposedly
represents
but there is a distinction just look at
what blm stands for
defeating the nuclear family trans
rights that sort of thing
these aren't the priorities of average
black voters and black families
these aren't the priorities of average
voters and families of any race
but democrats put all black people into
that box operating as if
to be black is to be a radical leftist
this is a failing strategy and they're
losing their grip on the minority vote
because of it
and that again is the case no matter how
this election shakes out
but of course all signs point to
leftists learning exactly the opposite
sorts of lessons here
like here's a tweet from a democrat
operative on twitter david adkins
he says progressives will recriminate
against centrists and vice versa but all
dem factions have to contend with this
turnout was high
the prague base showed up like prague's
want there was huge cross-partisan
outreach
like moderates want but trump activated
a massive racist
sexist vote i hate to admit it but this
election is less about what anyone on
the left center
left center center left did wrong but
rather
than the extraordinary challenge we have
in defeating this fascist movement
sure there are things we can do better
immediately most especially dealing with
what went wrong with the hispanic slash
latino vote
figuring out how to close the gap
between our candidates and support for
progressive
issues but there frankly aren't a lot of
great options because what it looks like
right now
is that dems were soft with poc men who
like trump's
toxic masculinity do we really want to
cater to that
pander more to the anti-chavistas
dial back our effort on police reform
and submit to the blue line flag folks
no easy answers if your answer is to go
farther to the center
you have to deal with the reality that
neither the biden nor clinton strategies
really worked
the cross-partisan alliance of decency
didn't materialize if your answer is to
go farther left well look at florida or
the rest belt the bright side
the country is clearly trending away
from from them the senate and electoral
college are saving them
but it's not trending away fast enough
to overcome an enormous backlash from
people
who simply refuse to give up white
supremacy toxic masculinity
and hardcore evangelical bible thumping
who are literally happy to suffer
hypothermia and die with tubes in their
throats for it
did you get that the problem is that a
lot of minorities are sexist
america is racist everyone's a bigot and
the solution presumably is to be
even louder and more obnoxious hectoring
scolds
and to work harder to get men especially
black men to hate themselves and their
masculinity
yes that's the key that's the ticket
glad to see they've learned something or
actually they've learned nothing
whatsoever
all right we'll have more to say in a
moment but i want to take a second first
to
tell you about expressvpn uh there are a
lot of
people dastardly people out there on the
internet making money by spying on you
that's not paranoia okay that's the
truth
so what's the best way to make sure that
100 of your data is encrypted
and that your internet provider can't
get a hold of it well you guessed it
expressvpn expressvpn
creates a secure tunnel between all your
devices and the internet
so that everything you do online is
encrypted it reroutes your connection
uh through a secure server this blocks
your internet
provider from seeing everything that you
do online it gives you the privacy that
you need online you should have and you
deserve all they can see is that you're
connected to an expressvpn server that's
all they say but nothing beyond that
and it's not just for your phone or
computer expressvpn works on all your
devices it works on your tablet smart
tvs
i mean everything can spy on you these
days again not not paranoia it's just
how it's set up
even your router can be protected so
your entire family can always stay
protected
i can't stress this enough expressvpn is
so simple to use
you just open up the app tap one button
to connect and that's it you don't have
to be a genius with
technological stuff if you did i
wouldn't be able to use it but i can use
it
you don't want people coming after you
don't want people knowing your
information you want your data to be
your business protect it at
expressvpn.comwelch
visit expressvpn.comwalsh to get three
months
of extra months of expressvpn protection
for free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh to learn more okay back to the
election
um what else do we know
we know that strange things seem to be
happening
and those strange things could affect
how the election shakes out for one
thing
some states stopped counting ballots in
the middle of the night
um nevada said it wasn't going to
release any more updates until november
5th
tomorrow there's no more updates and
there's never been there hasn't been any
good excuse offered for this
why would you stop counting why would
you stop updating in the middle of the
election
the best i've heard is that the counters
were tired and needed some sleep i'm
sorry
that doesn't cut it tired you got sleepy
this is a presidential election
nobody cares if you're tired you can't
leave the country in limbo so you can
grab some shut-eye
have you never heard of working in ships
there are many businesses many types of
operations that remain open 24 hours a
day
walmart does it your local 711 finds a
way to do it
does that mean that none of their
workers ever sleep no it means they work
in shifts
so you might think about that that
excuse just doesn't wash
and then we start reading reports like
this this here about um
large chunks of ballots in the k in this
case over a hundred thousand ballots
in michigan being counted and breaking
100 for biden this was a 100
000 vote chunk apparently reportedly
with not one single trump vote not one
how is that possible how is that
statistically possible and there have
been other
possible signs of shenanigans too and
here's the problem
this is why i'm concerned and you know
if you listen to this show you know i'm
not someone who runs around screaming
about voter fraud all the time
that that's not my thing normally but i
am worried here and i'll tell you why
aside from what i've already mentioned
democrats already subscribe to a
machiavellian
morally relativistic ends justify the
means worldview
and justify the means of course means
that you can do anything you want
anything is morally permissible as long
as the result is favorable
on top of that democrats have also
convinced themselves that they're
running against
literally hitler they believe they are
opposing satan incarnate
the very manifestation of evil so put
all this together ends justify
the means and the end is to rid
ourselves of a fascist dictator who's
killed 200 000 americans
and seeks to turn us into a handmaid's
tale dystopia
well in that case why wouldn't they
cheat if i had that world view that
philosophy and i thought i was going up
against hitler
i'd cheat too hell even as a person who
believes in objective morality
i'd still cheat to defeat hitler anybody
would which means
the only thing stopping democrats from
cheating is not any
moral compunction or any ethical
discipline on their part
but the system itself the system must
stop them from cheating
it comes down then to how much faith do
you have in the system
and your mileage on that score may vary
quite a bit
i should mention i tweeted about the 100
000 votes in michigan
um i said it was concerning okay
and trump retweeted it and here's what
that looks like now you can see it here
they censored my tweet they called it
misinformation
how could it be misinformation i'm
giving my opinion
i i'm informing people am i misinforming
people about my opinion
is that the accusation here so this is
nonsense from twitter
a mere expression of opinion about the
election now is
misinformation no that's not
misinformation
that's an opinion that our big tech
overlords don't agree with
and don't want you to see by the way i
wonder if they'd censor me for um
expressing my concern over this as sean
davis of the federalist
shows pennsylvania will will count
ballots without postmarks received days
after the election it says right here
ballots received in the mail by november
6th without postmarks will count
now call me crazy but i think voting
should end once voting ends
i think the conclusion of election day
should be the conclusion of voting in
fact
get this here's how here's how crazy i
really am i think the beginning of
election day
should be the beginning of voting the
end is the end the beginning is the
beginning
i think all votes should be cast on
election day in person
we can make exceptions for the military
but nobody else everybody else
if you're not on active duty in the
military should be at the polls in
person with your bright smiling face
on election day or your vote doesn't
count that's the only way to protect the
integrity of the system
that's the only way to ensure fast and
honest results that's the only way to
have fair elections with minimal chaos
if you can't make the time to vote
on the day of voting then it wasn't that
important to you
you got four years to plan for it if you
got something that comes up that day and
you can't make it to the polls well
sorry there's always next time he's not
gonna kill you you don't vote this year
no big deal
it's madness to have people voting for
president
weeks or months before the actual
election and then continue voting
after the election it's just madness i
can tell you this
my opinion on this issue has been
consistent and would remain the same
even if republicans mostly voted by you
know early or by mail this has nothing
to do with helping republicans for me
this has to do with establishing a sane
fare safe
honest system for voting but we what we
all know is that if republicans were the
ones doing the early voting and mail
voting democrats would certainly oppose
it
remember ends justify the means um it's
all about
the ends the result that's all that
matters
and and that's what we're we're up
against right now
now i kind of blew through our headlines
but i do have a um
daily cancellation uh an election themed
daily cancellation to get to
first before we do that though you know
um
you know what we could all use right now
i think some some rest some sleep i'm
going on about two hours of it
the ballot counters though got a cool
eight hours okay and hopefully they
rested well on a helix sleep mattress
listen helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you i've done it myself it really works
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm you sleep on your side your
back your stomach you sleep really hot
cold whatever it is with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique taste
you don't need to take their word for it
either helix was awarded the number one
best overall mattress of
2019 and 2020 by gq and wired magazine
there's a reason for that just go to
helixsleep.com
walsh take their two minute sleep quiz
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life i guarantee it
they have a 10 year warranty um then you
get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will love it it's
impossible to overstate the importance
of sleep i think we all feel that right
now especially today you need a good
night's sleep and
that's why you need helix sleep right
now helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders for our listeners at helix
sleep.com
walsh that's helix sleep dot com slash
walsh for up to 200
off your mattress order okay
now for our daily cancellation at first
uh i wasn't going to do any cancellation
today because i thought i'd just
ramble uh semi-coherently and semi-awake
about the election for 30 minutes but
i've decided to throw this in here
briefly because
there is a great candidate for
cancellation not someone that just i am
canceling but
that the voters of texas have canceled
yet again
and that is wendy davis otherwise known
as uh
abortion barbie major political office
um she's already done the house the
governorship
perhaps next the senate the presidency
she plans to become
one of the great losers of modern
american politics
and i hope she achieves that goal i
really do
now you may remember wendy davis she's
the woman who did that 13-hour long
filibuster in the texas
state senate in 2013 trying to prevent a
law
that would restrict abortion in the
state she valiantly stood for 13 hours
to defend the rights of abortionists
to dismember infants she failed in that
too ultimately as she fails in
everything as texas did end up passing
abortion restrictions
but for that 13-hour period and through
most of the rest of her pitiful
public career she established herself as
a thoroughly
bad person who would if she could only
manage it
climb atop the mass grave of thousands
of dead babies in order to achieve
esteem and political success success um
wendy davis is one of those aging bitter
feminist boomers
dissatisfied with her life having never
achieved success to match her ambition
and now set on trying to make the world
a more violent bitter and selfish place
hoping to
shape it to more closely resemble
herself she represents
basically everything that's wrong with
modern feminism in fact everything that
has always been wrong with feminism
on some level even from the beginning it
is self-centered
anti-family anti-child has always been
that way it has no warmth no love
it calls itself feminism but ironically
has no femininity
there is something so perverse and sad
and and just and just
just hideous about watching a woman
fight desperately to defend and promote
violence against children now maybe i
recoil from it
even more because i'm so used to you
know seeing the opposite of my own life
with my mother my four sisters now my
wife
all of the women closest to me love
children would die to protect children
would die for their own children
especially
feminist talking points simply have no
effect on them they laugh
uh they laugh at feminism it's an
absurdity
absurdity to them they you know they
have the kind of grace and dignity and
love that someone like wendy davis
can't even understand she can't
comprehend it because she is such a sh
hollow shallow empty person as are all
pro-abortion radical feminists hollow
empty ridiculous
and so wendy davis whose one great
career triumph
is to was to temporarily delay measures
that would protect children
is canceled she has been canceled again
by the voters
and i think few people in public life
deserve it more than she does okay
that's this is normally where i would
end it but uh but like i said i'm all i
you know i'm
all out of sorts as everybody is and i'm
not really following the normal format
and i did
i i just saw this it just popped up on
my screen as i was uh speaking
and okay this is from
this goes back to something we talked
about earlier but i didn't i didn't know
it was quite to this extent this is from
the national review here's the
the headline written by zachary evans it
says trump won the highest share of
non-white vote of any republican since
1960
according to exit polls and then it says
president trump has won the highest
share of non-white voters of any
republican presidential candidate since
1960.
uh roughly one-quarter of non-white
voters cast their ballots for trump
according to an edison exit poll
if the poll's an accurate reflection of
final results trump will have won over
one over more more non-white voters than
any republican since richard nixon who
won 32 percent of the non-white vote
in 1960 but lost to john kennedy trump
will also have improved on his
performance in the 2016 election
when he won 20 21 of the non-white vote
that's over 10 that he's increased um it
says democrats have attacked trump as
racist including during the 2016-2020
elections okay we know about that
however the edison polls showed that
support for trump rose among
african-americans asians and latinos a
particular 18 percent of black men
voted for trump in 2020 compared with 13
percent in 2016
and black women increased support for
trump from 4 to 8 percent
trump also roughly doubled his share of
gay voters
it appears that support among latinos um
also helped trump's victories in several
key counties in the sum belt trump was
able to score a win
in zapat zapeda zapata zapeda county
texas by 52 to 47 percent over joe biden
the county's population is 94
hispanic um and elected hillary clinton
over trump in 2016 by 65 to 32
all right well that's that is just
incredible that really is
that's um you're talking about now
you might say these numbers are still
small eight percent of the
of the black woman vote it doesn't give
the percentage of the gay vote but we
assume it's
it's comparatively low when you compare
it to democrats but
you're talking about a doubling of
support
and this is ha that's not happening in a
vacuum this is happening after four
years
one of the primary attacks on trump was
that he's a racist he's hitler like we
talked about he's a nazi
okay if you're if you're not a white
male he wants to
throw you into uh into the gulags or
something that's been the attack
we had blm we've got the riots and
everything all of this is based on
on this this has been their their
primary mode of attack
uh their primary argument about donald
trump is that he's a racist
and it hasn't worked we could look at
this and say
it straight up did not work at all it
didn't convince anybody
the only people that were convinced by
it we're already convinced
you know we can and even if they were i
mean the black voters that voted for for
democrats
in the last cycle and voted for for
democrats again
maybe they were convinced maybe they
weren't maybe they already believed that
republicans are racist whatever the case
may be
but but democrats actually lost voters
from that and you know we already talked
about why that is
but um i really think this is worth
of all the again no matter what happens
with the election no matter
if trump wins or loses and that right
now seems to be very much up in the air
i'm not going to predict
i i gave my project projection yesterday
that kanye west would win the presidency
that doesn't seem to have happened in
fact i should mention that he did
concede the race i believe
i don't give misinformation and get
punished by twitter but i i think i saw
that headline that he conceded the race
um and uh we you know we have to admit
that his path to victory probably at
this point
is very narrow so that's why i conceded
but anyway uh so i'm still not gonna
give my prediction on that but
no matter what happens this is you want
to talk about if there was any kind of
massive repudiation or backlash or
uh or anything like that it it was here
with the minority voters seeming to
reject
what the democrats were selling and
why is that well like like we already
discussed
um i i think
one thing is is probably for certain
here
you know democrats taking this this
attitude having this attitude that
if you're in this democratic this
demographic category
we own you you are ours
you you owe us your vote what was it
that joe biden said
if you vote if you don't vote democrat
you ain't black
okay unsurprisingly that's not a
convincing message
it's not just not convincing in fact it
is maybe convincing it's convincing in
the other way
nobody whether you're black white or
otherwise nobody wants to feel like
they have they belong to a certain
political party
or they owe their allegiance to a party
nobody wants to feel taken for granted
patronized
too i think the key with trump
is um among other things
one thing that trump does and yeah he's
accused of being a racist and a sexist
um but in fact people that
follow trump and that have paid
attention to him
you don't even have to pay that close
attention to notice this he talks to
everybody the same
and yeah he could be abrasive and vulgar
and profane sometimes
but he's that way to everybody he just
he approaches everyone exactly the same
this is this is not someone who panders
and so if you're a black voter if you're
hispanic voter he's going to give you
the same pitch he gives everybody else
yeah he does a little bit of his of his
pandering by saying i'm the best
president for black people since abraham
lincoln
and that sort of thing but for the most
part his message to everybody is the
same
like the message hate the message it's
the same to everyone whereas with
democrats
they're going to break you down into
little categories and
this is their message for this group and
here's their message for that group
we talked about this on the show and i
think you could probably still go to joe
biden's website
and find it but um you go to joe biden's
website
and you go to his plan for america his
agenda
and he's got a specific plan for every
sub category of people he's got a plan
for black voters he's got a plan for gay
voters
jewish voters catholic voters older
people
younger people hispanic uh lgbt
he's breaking them all down and here's
joe's plan for all these different
groups
they got it yes you got to segregate
them in different categories
acting as though we don't all at the end
of the day want basically the same
things
i think that that i i hope i pray i
think that maybe that
is there's finally um some backlash to
that
and uh and finally that method is
breaking down
the intersectional house of cards maybe
is collapsing
if there is one big sort of wave one big
thing to come out of this election it's
it's maybe that i would hope and pray
for that anyway
and you know the other thing i would
also say in closing
is um there are two things
that most normal people
actually value despite what democrats
may tell you and despite what they want
family and uh and country
now people value other things aside from
those but those are things that people
value
they care about their families and also
they they do love their country
and they don't want to hate their
country it doesn't mean they think their
country is right about everything it
doesn't mean they can't they can't
stomach any criticism of their country
but feeling proud of your country that's
something that that most
people want and enjoy
you see the flag you know during the
national anthem most people want to
stand for the national anthem
and that's doesn't matter what your race
is
the democrats what are they what do they
tell you black lives matter we're going
to break down the nuclear family
what kind of you have to be far
left crazy radical for that to be a
priority
in your life
not only do you not value the family but
you actually see it as a negative you
want to destroy it that's not how most
people operate
and most people i think don't want to
hate their country
the the thing that trump does where he
sees an american flag and he'll hug the
american flag
cradle it in his arms it's a little bit
weird and corny but
at the same time that's that's much more
what people want to see from their
president especially and how they feel
about
the country that's much closer to it
than you know the athletes who are
taking a knee and protesting the anthem
so maybe there's maybe there's something
significant happening there too
but as i said we're we're still getting
the results and um
we'll find out so who knows what the
situation will be tomorrow when uh
i talk to you again but we will all
continue praying and uh
being vigilant in the meantime talk
tomorrow have a great day
godspeed
the matt wall show was produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle we'll tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there